es poeta catedrático de literatura
española en la universidad de granada y
director del instituto cervantes de la
institución pública española que tiene
por objeto promover la enseñanza el
estudio y el uso del español luis garcía
montero gracias por recibir a france 24
gracias gracias a vosotros
en qué estado está la expansión de
nuestro idioma por el mundo tiene sus
hablantes nativos pero fuera de eso
cuánto ha crecido bueno no nos podemos
quejar
somos casi 500 millones de hablantes
nativos y nos acercamos a más de 600
millones
de gente que estudia el idioma que
aprende el idioma en lugares importantes
como eeuu
desde el punto de vista económico o como
asia pero también tiene desarrollo en el
áfrica sub-sahariana de manera que no
nos podemos quejar de la vigencia de
nuestro idioma es el segundo idioma con
mayor número de hablantes nativos
después del chino mandarín y el segundo
idioma creo yo en comunicación y cultura
después del inglés y que les falta para
desarrollar seguir más allá a volverse
si se quiere más hegemónico si es que
vale que un idioma se vuelve un poco más
hegemónico bueno les creo que es muy
importante
el diálogo entre las lenguas hegemónicas
y las lenguas no hegemónicas que nos
falta pues yo creo que aprender que el
español no es sólo la lengua de
cervantes o de borges que tiene que ser
una lengua científica y una lengua
tecnológica y por eso para el instituto
cervantes ha sido tan importante
colaborar con la uva con la universidad
de buenos aires porque todos que sea
progresar en el español como lengua de
ciencia y lengua de tecnología va a
servirnos para desarrollar nuestras
sociedades si la lengua se habla
principalmente en américa latina porque
la mayoría de sus salarios están en
américa latina va a llegar un día en que
haya un director una directora del
instituto que sea latinoamericano o eso
sigue siendo algo es que hegemonizan te
quiero trabajar todo el terminado de
españa fíjate en la
de fundación del instituto cervantes se
reivindicaba la cultura española para
decir que en españa aparte del español
está el catalán el gallego el euskera y
nuestra tarea es promocionar los y la
cultura en español que era reconocer que
formamos parte de una comunidad donde
los españoles sólo somos el 8% y en ese
sentido
somos los más interesados en defender
que este idioma no tiene centro que no
se habla mejor en un sitio que en otro
que en cada sitio se habla el español
cómo se habla materna mente en cada
sitio y no se habla mejor en bogotá que
en el río de la plata o en el río de la
plata que en méxico en méxico que en
españa o en salamanca que en andalucía
en cada sitio se habla el español y cómo
se habla maternalmente y en este sentido
el instituto cervantes es una
institución española
acostumbraba a hacer la mayoría de sus
actividades en colaboración con
instituciones latinoamericanas
puede perfectamente haber un director
con doble nacionalidad además desde
de todo lo que todo lo que hicimos que
era también el medio de almudena gran
gran novelista española que falleció en
noviembre del año pasado de 2021 estoy
hablando entrevista del diario el país
de la felicidad de los últimos días
compartidos después interesante en este
momento de pandemia en que hubo tantas
pérdidas para tantas personas rescatar
esa idea de la felicidad de ese último
tiempo de poder diseñarlo sobre todo en
el recuerdo porque mientras lo vives es
duro pero la posibilidad de cuidarnos es
muy importante muy importante el cuidar
el ser cuidado el saber que nos une la
debilidad más que la prepotencia es muy
importante en todos los sectores de la
vida y porque tiene que ver con el amor
más que con el dominio y bueno pues
cuando uno recuerda pasado el tiempo los
momentos antes de la pérdida donde
pudimos cuidarnos y pudimos compartir
esa necesidad pues ayuda a la esperanza
hemos tenido mala suerte almudena no
venció la enfermedad pero hay mucha
gente que la está venciendo
y quien le toca es a
esa amargura pues conviene que no pierda
la esperanza porque hay mucha gente
los supera gracias a los cuidados
personales familiares o científicos
públicos qué bien que contemos con una
ciencia que pueda salvar vidas
luis garcía montero muchas gracias
gracias a vosotros de verdad de corazón
y ustedes muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en france 24 los invitamos
a seguir con nuestra programación y a
visitar nuestro contenido en france 24
punto com